this is James right for you an American
citizen of your country Sky News is
chosen not to broadcast this video it's
too graphic but it shows journalist Jim
Foley in the final minutes of his life
on his knees in an orange jumpsuit with
a man dressed in black standing over him
the audio reveals that his killer has a
British accent as a government you had
been at the forefront of the aggression
towards the Islamic state you have
plotted against us and gone far out of
your way to find reasons to interfere in
our affairs so any attempt by you Obama
to deny the Muslims their rights of
living in safety under the Islamic
caliphate result in the bloodshed of
your people James Foley is beheaded in
the film the White House said agents
were working to authenticate this video
but said if it was genuine it was
appalled by the brutal murder of an
innocent journalist this is a message to
the brothers or stayed behind the
British connection will worry number 10
this isn't the first young Britain to
have appeared in an Islamic state video
we have brothers from Bangladesh from
Iraq from Cambodia Australia UK nothing
has gathered us except to make a lot so
just with the highest james foley was
kidnapped in syria in november 2012 but
it wasn't the first time he'd been
detained he was taken by pro-gaddafi
forces in Libya several years earlier
and spent months in jail when he
returned after six weeks he reflected on
the risks of reporting from war zones we
hitched a ride up to the front lines and
we were told that Qadhafi forces were
very close we decided to get off the
road because we felt it was safer due to
normally shelling coming from the road
unfortunately Qadhafi forces came right
over the hill and within seconds we were
under heavy fire he was soon back in the
field in Syria recording the suffering
of innocence in war until he was
kidnapped
his parents John and Diane Foley
launched an Internet campaign to secure
their son's release I appealed to the
people who have Jim to let us know where
he is and to help us really secure his
release and to give us some information
in terms of his is is welfare is health
on the charity facebook page set up to
find him his mother wrote we have never
been prouder of our son Jim he gave his
life trying to expose the world to the
suffering of the Syrian people we
implore the kidnappers to spare the
lives of the remaining hostages like Jim
they are innocence they have no control
over American government policy in Iraq
Syria or anywhere in the world we thank
Jim for all the joy he gave us he was an
extraordinary son brother journalist and
person please respect our privacy in the
days ahead as we mourn and cherished Jim
the Islamic state which claimed
responsibility for the beheading says
that if US air strikes on is militants
in Iraq don't stop another journalist
will be executed it's the most dangerous
place in the world you know I've been in
Iraq Afghanistan and Libya I was
fighting in the war and and by far
serious most dangerous place you don't
really you really don't know you don't
know who to trust you don't know what's
gonna happen it's just insanity and it's
turned into a black hole that
journalists and aid workers go in there
and they disappear President Obama
returned to Martha's Vineyard to resume
his holiday after breaking off to deal
with the situation in Iraq just as the
video was made public now the gruesome
turn of events will again weigh heavy on
his mind Sam Kiely Sky News